[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock here in the united kingdom
you're very welcome to spend your
breakfast with us wherever you're
watching us here on sky news right
around the world this morning feeling
the squeeze higher gas spills for many
families already facing universal credit
cards and a national insurance hike as
energy companies fight for survival the
message to those firms the prize cap is
here to stay what's the business
secretary quasi quatting doing about it
all quite a big job today we'll ask him
in just a second also
that sort of morning it's all gone pete
tong 8 45 speaking to the dj legend
about how the music helps bring friends
and family together
in addition
opening up about grief dancers aj and
curtis will be with me at 9 45 to tell
us why they're encouraging all of us to
talk about the experience of losing our
loved ones it's tuesday the 21st of
september
fears for the future as the business
secretary tells energy companies the
price cap is here to stay plus what next
for families and food supplies
criminally negligent the government
faces criticism after a data breach
involving the details of 250 afghan
interpreters
the prime minister will be here at the
west wing of the white house for an oval
office meeting with president biden the
pandemic and american commitments on
climate change will top the agenda
i'm at the u.s embassy as british
airways reports a 700
increase in interest for u.s holidays
after the country said it will welcome
fully vaccinated passengers from the uk
and the eu
questions over the whereabouts of prince
andrew after a civil sexual assault
lawsuit is delivered to his u.s lawyer
in the line of fire lava oozes through
the streets of la palma destroying
houses as a volcano on the island
continues to erupt
[Music]
morning everybody what lies in store for
families this winter already feeling the
squeeze from the planned universal
credit card and national insurance hike
some are already experiencing higher gas
bills as energy companies struggling
with spiraling wholesale prices are
forced to ask for bailouts how many can
survive to the end of the year the
business secretary says the price cap
will remain good news for some customers
but bad news for smaller energy
businesses grazie quatting is here hi
good morning what a challenging few days
you've got ahead well it's been uh
interesting but we're very focused on
trying to get through this okay so talk
to me about how big a crisis we're
facing i think what your viewers have to
understand is that every
winter
a number of some energy suppliers
exit the market they leave because
they can't uh maintain their financial
position this year the wholesale prices
are going up very high
so the price at which they get uh gas
uh is much higher
and of course that puts more pressure on
them and that's why a number of these
companies are saying that we should uh
some of them are saying we should lift
the price cap some of them are saying
that we should perhaps bail them out
and i've been very focused on three
principles i think firstly we've got to
look after customers we've got to make
sure there's a continuity of supply and
we've got to look after the most
vulnerable and particularly elderly
customers that's my first priority the
second thing i've said is that i don't
think
we should be
throwing taxpayers money at companies
which have been let's face it badly run
a number of these companies have been
badly run as i say every year uh between
five and eight companies exit the market
and i don't want to prop up uh failing
companies i don't want to there to be a
reward for failure i don't think the
taxpayer should be propping those up and
then the third principle is that
as you said in your header the energy
price cap is here to stay i don't want
to
remove that i don't want to go back to
the old days where very very small
number of companies
were essentially um pushing up prices
and
extorting lots of value from from
customers who had no choice problem is
that price cap policies can't cope with
extremes can they that's that's the main
issue and it's a mistaken intervention
some would say by a conservative
government to to cap prices yeah that is
an argument but what we had before only
a few years ago
was a market where you had very small
number of
companies
that were charging very very high prices
and that's why we brought in the price
cap but what the price cap has done has
actually forced companies to innovate
they've been lots of new entrants as
we've seen
and now we're at a point where some of
those new entrants are feeling the
pressure and some of them uh it may well
be have have not been managed properly
state backed loans is an option there
lots of options i mean currently at the
moment and it's important people
understand this we have mechanisms in
place so there's a thing called solar
which stands for the supplier of last
resort which means that if your energy
company goes bust
the customers from that company will go
uh to another company which can absorb
the number of customers these these
structures are already there the issue
this year as you know is that there may
be more than the usual five to eight
it's good
it won't be a house of cards but there
should be more than five to eight uh
there could be more than five to eight
it's not happened yet there could be
more than five to eight uh the usual
companies that that exit
uh and we have to have a much more
robust uh supply of last resort uh how
many of you should have two before
what's your worst case scenario on the
number of companies i'm not going to put
a number on that um as i say most years
i mean i've been energy minister for
this my third year third winter uh five
to eight is is generally uh what's what
we've observed
and it could be it could be worse than
that but i i can't tell you the exact
number so what's going to happen to all
of those customers the customers and
this is my first principle
we'll have a complete continuity of
supplies so we will find energy
suppliers there will be energy suppliers
for those customers and that's what the
supplier of last resort the the
mechanism we already have in place
that's what it means which is why you
need to look um to stake back loans for
some of those bigger companies to
support and those who are taking on
extra customers yeah those are some of
the ideas that are discussed you're
quite right because it costs a company
uh to absorb
up to hundreds of thousands of customers
from another company that's failed that
costs money and there may well be
a provision for some sort of loan
and that's been discussed that's been
widely reported okay so when will you
make decisions on that i'm speaking to
small
suppliers today i spent the whole
weekend speaking to the regulator i
spoke to larger suppliers
and we're getting around a roundtable of
smaller suppliers
and we want to get a full range of
market opinion how do we find ourselves
in this position i think that uh they've
been uh extreme uh
the volatile commodity prices last year
we saw the oil price was 20.1 one in
april roughly and then it went up to 80
and it's coming back down a bit uh with
gas prices this year we've had obviously
the coveted pandemic huge demand coming
out of asia and that's spiked the price
uh and that's one of the things one of
the features of the postcovid recovery
yeah what about um worst case scenarios
you said yesterday in the house of
commons that it was alarmist to say that
people would struggle to heat their
homes in the winter months yeah so my uh
thinking behind that the reason i said
that
is that there are two issues here the
gas prices
and then of course there's the security
of supply the idea that somehow we won't
get be able to get enough of the stuff
what i was trying to say yesterday and
what i said yesterday was that
security of supply is not an issue we've
got lots of diverse
sources of gas
uh the structure of the market in terms
of the energy suppliers that is an issue
and that's what we've been talking about
well you say that people um won't um
struggle to heat their homes in the
winter months but of course they do
already
um
the
the issue i was saying i was well yeah
in terms of cost but i'm just saying
that there is constant continuity of
supply that was what i i was focusing on
we're mixing up two things here not
really because the bottom line is you
can either heat your home or you can't
no the the reasons why you can either
heat it because it costs a lot of money
or you can you or you you can't heat it
because there simply isn't enough gas
and one of the concerns that was
expressed yesterday was that we would
simply wouldn't have
enough of the gas we wouldn't have
enough of the stuff uh to be able to
heat our homes and that was the
mis uh impression that was the the the
myth if you like i was trying to bust
yesterday yeah but the reason that
people can't hit their homes is because
they can't afford the gas yes and
obviously gas prices are going to go up
aren't they you'll say that there's a
price cap but hundreds of thousands of
people are about to come off their fixed
term tariffs and their prices are going
to go up so the price cap as you know
has uh really kept prices down
for hundreds of thousands if not
millions of customers
the gas companies are saying the energy
companies are saying they want to lift
the price cap because they want to raise
prices but i've said that we're keeping
the price cap yeah but my point is that
people are coming off their fixed term
tariffs and as a result their prices
could go up up to did i read something
like 1500 pounds more no i don't i don't
reckon so what figures do you recognize
so i think that uh what will happen uh
and we've got to wait and see what
happens to the market we've got to wait
and see what happens uh to the suppliers
uh but i've said because of the capital
so in terms of uh trying to limit uh
rises uh we shouldn't be uh in a
situation where people are paying uh
the amount that you said so what is the
worst case scenario for people who are
coming off those fixed term tariffs i
think that people uh should be able to
find uh uh pricing which is very much in
line with their old uh with their on
their old tariff but as you say we've
got to wait and see
how many of the suppliers are affected
clearly there's a world of difference if
as you you is usually the case five to
eight suppliers uh exit the market leave
or if it's if it's more than that and
the figures in the ft yesterday saying
you know there could be dozens you don't
you don't recognize i don't recognize
that i mean i've just in terms of
background when i became an engineer
more than two years ago there were 65
suppliers
today the figure i think is about 55.
i'm going to need to check that because
obviously yeah yeah it fluctuates um do
i think that they'll be fit there has to
be am i going to bail out all 55 of
those companies if in an extreme case no
i don't think we can do that because
some of those companies a handful of
them
probably would have exited anyway so i
don't see why
what's the criteria for bailing them out
well they've got to look at we've got to
look at their financial position uh some
of these companies probably would have
exited anyway and there's no point so
some of these businesses are just
chances that they like it when it's a
sunny day and when actually they find
themselves in a position where they're
not making money because of the price
cap then they come cap in hand to the
government is that what that sometimes
happens i mean that's one of the reasons
why as i said every year that i've been
in the job five to eight companies have
exited the market for various reasons
and the conservative government is not
going to build businesses out there i
don't think it makes any sense to put
taxpayers money your money our money to
companies that have been badly run
are you going to bail out this business
that
makes carbon dioxide for the food
industry but has had to close because
it's just not financially viable at the
moment we're definitely looking at
trying to secure
carbon dioxide
uh supply
uh and it's
well i think i think we're getting that
i mean i spoke to the chancellor
yesterday uh spoken to the the ceo of
the business an american man the f
industries uh yep tony will spoken to
him twice he flew over
uh on sunday i spoke to him on sunday
lunchtime we didn't have a lunch but we
uh spoke very uh candidly about the
situation of his company how did that
conversation okay it was a it was a
frank conversation he said that the
problem he had was that the natural gas
price is much higher than the ammonia
which he sells so essentially what
happened last week was the the the plant
down tools
and i said of course we've got to
manufacture this uh
co2 and that's what we're we're talking
about this week
so we don't have much time as far as
that's concerned it's pretty imminent
but uh i'm i'm confident today tomorrow
in the next
three this week i hope uh we we have a
very clear plan
to get the co2 production going i mean
that's pretty big deal if he's flying
over to have a chat especially given how
challenging it is to fly at the moment
so did you get him to come so you could
talk to him i didn't oh he wanted to uh
come and see
us see me in government i went to the
office we had a very good conversation
about the situation and we're determined
to but you made it clear that we can't
not have these factories open
that's a a very clear steer that i gave
okay and you think by the end of the
week we'll have that sorted out i am
very confident and hopeful that we can
sort it out by the end of the week isn't
it
somewhat frustrating that we find
ourselves in a position where we're
being held um to ransom by a business
like this how could we find ourselves in
that position why don't we see it coming
we uh have lots of contingency plans um
the the gas uh distribution is is very
wide
but in this particular instance
the manufacturer of uh co2
was critically dependent on natural gas
where you've got skyrocketing rocketing
prices what we've done is we've looked
at how we can get the production going
again and i'm hopeful confident that
we'll be able to do that because it is
time critical as you're pointing out i
was reading just yesterday that pig
farmers
i've got all these pigs that need to go
to market chicken farmers as well and if
they're not done by the end of the week
they have to slaughter all these animals
and put them in landfill you're
absolutely right and that's one why the
carbon dioxide situation is critical and
that's why i spent all of you what are
we going to do about that going forward
to make sure that we're not finding
ourselves in that position in future i
think we have to have a diversity of
sources of carbon dioxide
cff isn't the only company
that manufactures
uh carbon dioxide why are we so reliant
on them um they have a big share of the
market i said they weren't the only ones
but they are they're a big part of the
carbon dioxide market
and as far as our gas supply is
concerned how concerned are we that the
russians are basically controlling how
much gas we get and don't get i think
the levels are down to 20 percent of
pre-pandemic levels i don't uh think
that there's much concern as far as
we're concerned
from where we get our gas very little of
our
gas comes from russia
fifty percent of it is sourced here in
the uk
and thirty percent that comes from
norway and i spoke to the norwegian
energy minister yesterday and she was
very confident
that that supplier from norway
was was secure they've also said in a
way that they're going to increase
production so they're going to increase
capacity of next week
to make sure that we we get the gas we
need we're very reliable on the reliant
i should say on the spot market though
we we don't seem to have the storage
capability that we had previously i
think there was a place in the north sea
where it closed in 2017 was it 2017 2017
yeah and we don't have that big storage
facility anymore which means that we are
very susceptible to the ranges in price
yeah we i mean it's you've got to
remember okay it's a globe it's
something we should do it's a global i
look at these things all the time it's a
global price spike so every country uh
certainly in europe particularly about
storage should be looking at storage
i completely uh understand that but i'm
just trying to put a context no i
understand um this uh spike is
completely unprecedented we've had a
global pandemic there's a huge uptick in
demand and everyone is trying to get the
same uh
sources of gas and that's what caused
the spike now i think in this situation
you're right we need to look at our
energy strategy going forward i think
it's been fairly resilient if you look
at renewables if you look at the range
of sources of electricity it's pretty
wide much wider than a number of other
countries and that's something that is a
credit to the uk one of the other
options i suppose to keep people's gas
bills under control or fuel bills is to
pause the green levy is that something
you might think about no i haven't i
mean you'll appreciate it'll say that
that's uh an issue for the the
chancellor because it's a it's a fiscal
tax yeah but you can actually speak to
him yeah i do speak to you a lot um but
i think the green that we love is pretty
much in its infancy and actually we've
been very successful at moving away from
fossil fuels
to renewables uh renewable sources of
power and that's that's a british
success story i don't know if you ever
we have a climate show here on sky news
that we we run i've been on it a couple
of times yeah for six every evening we
have sort of like a projection of how
much fuel is being used every single day
and every single minute um at the moment
we're using a lot of fossil fuels that
makes the price um a bit more concerning
doesn't it just looking at it actually
as we see 57 that's significantly higher
than what it normally is yeah that's the
in terms of gas you'll know that in that
the coal figure has gone down uh hugely
so even just eight years ago we had 40
percent was from coal burning
essentially and that today that's about
two percent so we've done a a good job
in moving away from coal but you're
right that natural gas uh is still a big
part of the uh of the energy supply okay
not something that we can worry about
just at the moment we need to try and
make sure that we get the supply as best
we can i wonder if i can talk to you
about this mod data breach before i let
you go what can you tell us about this
data breach regarding afghan
interpreters that is very concerning
it's very concerning and as far as i
know uh the well i do know the secretary
of state for defense has launched an
inquiry into this um clearly that's
something that is deeply worrying i
think it will cause a lot of concern
certainly with allies and interpreters
and friends in afghanistan and i hope we
can get to the bottom of them that's all
i can say about this okay are you
worried that lives could be at risk as a
result well look i think it's uh
very difficult uh when people you know
data is breached and people know
what others have been doing
but let's get to the bottom of the
investigation so that's a yes really
i just want to say that uh i think it's
it's a serious situation just before i
let you go i just reassure my viewers if
you would this morning i mean you're
very you you've sat in a relaxed ration
you're very calm um very
leveled voice but a lot of people will
be worried about heating their homes and
putting food on the table over the next
few weeks i think
the next few days are going to be quite
challenging
but i'm very confident critical and then
stopped no no i said they're quite
challenging um don't put words into my
life no i'm asking you
you know i've been in post i've been
energy minister for more than two years
now i've been secretary of state now for
nearly a year i've spoken to all many of
the major players i've spoken to the
regulator and i'm very confident that
we'll be able to get through this
and we'll look back
and say that we did a good job in terms
of getting through what was a global
situation it was a difficult global
situation and i think in the uk
we'll be able to navigate our way
through it and what can we do as um and
end-of-the-line users what can we do to
try to help in the meantime i think
people need to look at their gas prices
and they need to look at um what what
else is out there
potentially in the market i think people
need to be aware that there are lots and
lots of suppliers
and they are varying quality like in any
market where you've got 50 or 60
different suppliers they're not all
up to the same level some of them are
well capitalized well run others
less so and i think consumers probably
need to take a little bit more of an
active interest i don't think we should
you know try and all the gas experts but
just in terms of energy bills just to
see
what's out there
um is this the biggest challenge you
faced in your face the number of uh yeah
in your two years this this year there
was a a an energy blackout um two weeks
into the job
uh and commuters will remember i think a
million commuters were essentially
blacked out there was no electricity the
trains weren't moving that was in august
2019 uh we had a whole issue with
fracking uh and you know 2.9 on the
richter scale so is it in an energy how
does this compare this is this is very
serious and also it has it's it's got a
global
dimension to it in a way that some of
those other crises didn't but it's you
know it's it's a very volatile market
there's a lot going on in the global
economy you mentioned russia there's
geopolitics there's so many different uh
strands so many different forces acting
on this market and and it's a
challenging and stimulating job that i
do i have to let you go um but it's good
to talk to you i'm glad i'm sat here and
not there today
challenging few days ahead for you thank
you very much indeed
thank you i just reminded if you want to
catch up on any of our interviews you
can watch the programme when you're out
and about this morning you can find us
on the mobile app or you can go to our
website
and the live blog is there as well and
you can catch up on the interviews on my
twitter as well if you would like to and
that is at k burley
lot to go out there helen and good
morning good morning
yeah lots to go out there i think the
minister really wanted to make clear
that people should feel reassured i
think that message came across very
clearly didn't it he wanted to tell
us and the viewing public that customers
are going to be protected uh that the
vulnerable will be looked after this
winter that that price cap that keeps
energy prices in check that's going to
remain and that crucially that
taxpayer's money is not going to be put
towards bailing out some of these big
companies but certainly i think watching
that some energy companies some
consumers as well would have wanted
potentially to hear a bit more there was
lots of potential solutions and
interventions being discussed yesterday
a bad bank potentially to take on some
of those customers from companies that
had collapsed the potential for
state-backed loans still an option
potentially other interventions as well
and i think some people will have said
you know reassurance is one thing and
that's good but we want to hear more
minister
there was a sort of acknowledgement
there that there is some structural
problems in the energy industry and a
sense i think that they want to try and
address some of that and there were i
think some more positive noises as well
about that co2 crisis a sense that a
deal on that or some sort of
intervention will be coming this week uh
as we know the end the sort of meat and
poultry pig industry have said that we
could be seeing shortages on the shelves
have there easy flights to try and sort
it out indeed absolutely and we could be
seeing those shortages in a matter of
days potentially but look you know this
crisis will continue to escalate the
minister has acknowledged um that a
number more small
companies might go under and we have to
remember that while he says people are
going to be protected lots of consumers
may feel as their national insurance is
going up as their universal credit
uplift comes to an end as furlough comes
to an end they may feel not very
protected for themselves and that's his
job over the next couple of days that's
for sure
thanks so much indeed we were also
discussing with the minister weren't we
that that the government is facing
criticism from all sides after the
ministry of defense confirmed a data
breach involving the details of 250
afghan interpreters um
ali fortescue is down at the ministry of
defence for us this morning hi ali you
heard what the minister said what do you
think
well i mean i think it's very serious uh
you you heard that he he wouldn't say
that lives were under threat but that is
certainly the warning from many
cross-party politicians today these are
250 afghan interpreters translators that
have been working with the british army
and we understand they're being emailed
as part of a scheme that was about
relocating people in afghanistan unclear
right now whether all these people are
indeed in afghanistan or in the uk but
their names it appears have been copied
into
an email which has given their their
details in some cases email addresses
and even profile pictures that have been
openly copied in so it's a huge um least
significant data breach and we're saying
you know the second for the ministry of
defense remember back in
june there were papers that were found
at a bus stop but sensitive security
information so um there they have faced
cross-party criticism including from
johnny mercer who is the former defense
minister he has tweeted to say the truth
on how we've treated our afghan
interpreters will out all the
backslapping over pitting that is the
operation to get people out of
afghanistan marks a criminally negligent
performance for mormons by the ministry
of defence and the home office on doing
our duty to these people i reiterate the
vast majority have been left behind
probably moving house again tonight so
very serious warning there from johnny
mercer about the impact on those still
in afghanistan okay ali for now thanks
so much indeed ali for
speaking to us live from the ministry of
defense this morning now tending to the
uh special relationship at 7 30 you'll
be speaking to a former british
ambassador to the united states sir
david manning as joe biden prepares to
welcome boris johnson to the white house
ambitious and excited for the future at
quarter 28 speaking to the children's
commissioner about why many young people
remain optimistic despite having lived
through covers
[Music]
will be joined by the author of comic
book telling inspirational stories of 50
people chosen by the rapper and one of
those he says he has uh has inspired him
i should say
the us president joe biden will become
boris johnson's uh will certainly
welcome him at the white house later on
today in their first meeting after a
summer which strained transatlantic ties
with the chaotic withdrawal from
afghanistan our u.s correspondent mark
stone reports from washington
it's been just three months since the
prime minister and the president last
met at the g7 in cornwall
but what a long tricky summer it's been
transatlantic relationships have been
strained the pandemic endures and
november's high-stakes climate change
summit is ever closer
the president's focus in new york will
be to mend alliances fractured by
afghanistan and to tackle the
extraordinary fallout with france over
australian submarines he'll deliver a
key speech at the un this morning
with johnson and biden both in new york
their meeting could easily have been
held there too but instead they'll have
it in washington
holding it here at the white house
carries much more weight that special
relationship which has been put to the
test in recent weeks looks that much
more convincingly special with a meeting
held at the oval office
on afghanistan prime minister johnson
took flack from an american decision and
a chaotic exit and yet now speaking to
an american audience on nbc he was
reluctant to criticize the president
america has been there for for 20 years
and
it's
a it's a respectable argument to say
that uh
enough is enough you can't endlessly uh
subcontract the the government of your
country to other people there's got to
be some sort of system so do you agree
with that
it sounds like you do look i mean
could we have done it
a bit differently maybe we could
on the pandemic the white house
announcement yesterday that it will lift
the travel ban in november removes one
point of tension it allows space for the
two leaders to focus on the bigger
picture vaccinating the world the white
flag is a stark reminder of the cost of
the pandemic each represents a life lost
and then there's the climate president
biden's climate envoy hinted to sky news
that america will meet britain's calls
for more funds for poorer countries to
fight climate change united states will
do its part
so you're hoping president biden will
add more funds this week i'm not hoping
i'm
telling you stay tuned to the
president's speech
the optics of these moments through the
years are of course important but it's
the results that matter on climate boris
johnson may get something to take with
him to glasgow but on that all-important
post-brexit trade deal well don't hold
your breath mark stone sky news in
washington
and sir david manning former british
ambassador to the united states is with
us now hello to you thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
sir david and that's the bottom line
isn't it a lot of this is window
dressing unless you can get this brexit
deal with the us
well i think these meetings are always
important so i don't think a bilateral
meeting between the prime minister and
the president is just window dressing
and i agree with mark staying your
correspondent that the fact that it's
going to be in washington is important
but of course you're right it's what
comes out of these meetings that matters
in the long run and there are some very
big things on this agenda today
particularly for you
well i think the things that i'd be
looking for are what is going to come
out of their discussions about the
american commitment on climate change
the uh the cop 26 meeting that's taking
place in glasgow shortly is very
important
certainly for the success of british
diplomacy but for the future of the
whole climate agenda and what the
president has to say to the prime
minister today is going to be crucial to
the success or otherwise of those talks
i think
um and there is there is repair work to
do as well i mean let's be candid um
it's been a very tricky summer as your
correspondent said
the
i think the government's
was shaken by the way in which the
united states decided to withdraw from
afghanistan we were left with a debacle
20 years almost a day after 9 11.
and this is not exactly how we expected
this administration to behave when it
talks about uh strengthening alliances
so there has been a a shock to
confidence it's important that that is
now
rebuilt i think i also hope that they
will talk about ways in which it's
possible to repair the uh
the the strained relationship now with
france over the important new
arrangements for security in the pacific
it's a it's a obviously very important
step forward that there is this new
agreement
to
contain
the chinese rise through this new uh
submarine agreement with australia but
at the same time we we have to
accept that the french have had a nasty
shock over this and we need them very
much to help our security in in nato so
there are some very big strategic issues
for for the or the two leaders to
discuss i think
yeah levels of cooperation um are
potentially uh challenged at the moment
some people might say and there was a
recent poll apparently seven in ten
americans believe that we need them more
than um the other way around uh we need
they need us there we go i got there
eventually um and in addition to that
we're opening this travel corridor from
november it seemed to come somewhat as a
surprise to the brit so there isn't that
necessarily that communication that was
there previously
well i think we've been asking as i
understand it for that corridor to be
reopened for for months and so of our um
our colleagues in the in the european
union i mean reconnecting north america
to europe
uh as far as we're concerned is vital
for all sorts of reasons for economic
reasons and trade reasons and tourist
reasons um so i think it's very welcome
and it has of course a high symbolism at
a time when we're hoping that we can get
over the the bumps of the last few
months the fact that we can now travel
to one another's countries without
restriction is uh is if you like a
visual expression of that so i'm sure
it's very welcome
politically as well as economically
yeah absolutely and i don't disagree
with you on that at all i suppose my
point was that it seemed to come
somewhat of a surprise after all of the
campaigning yes no i i quite agree with
you i think
clearly from what one gathers it has
come as a surprise but perhaps it's
because the american administration
decided to you know save it up as
something uh positive to present when uh
in in the margins of
meeting
european counterparts at the un general
assembly
what do you think boris johnson would
see as a win when he comes home um on
the plane from the united states well i
think his his big hope must be that um
that there is this commitment from the
president to to do more on on climate
change particularly to contribute to a
fund for
the developing countries as they as they
have to take the strain of new
arrangements so i think that would
certainly be a big win and would be a
big help for
uh in preparing for cop 26 in a few
weeks time which is not a
straightforward meeting it's a very big
and difficult meeting i think it's also
the
if i can put it this way the dog that
doesn't bark which is um that there is
nothing difficult that comes out of this
meeting over the whole question of the
uh us
administration's attitude to our um
you know the northern ireland uh
agreement through with the um darling
protocol
as part of the brexit agreement there's
no secret in nancy pelosi the
uh the the leader of the uh the
democrats in the congress said said in
london last week that they are very keen
indeed that the united kingdom and the
eu find a solution to their dispute over
the northern ireland protocol and that
there won't be
a free trade agreement between the
united kingdom and the united states if
that relationship is not resolved so i
think that is also an area which uh i
imagine they will want to talk about and
i hope that they will find that that
they can find some kind of common ground
on that but i'm sure that's also an
important element in these discussions
yeah a lot for them to cram in today
isn't that thank you very much indeed
for joining us this morning ambassador
thank you
i'm sure the pandemic will come up as
well when the two men are speaking at
the white house let me give you the
latest figures as far as the uk is
concerned on the coveted data
fourteen and a half thousand first doses
of a covid vaccine were given in the
latest 24-hour period uh 35 000 people
received their second dose
almost 45 million people are now fully
vaccinated
36 100 new cases of coronavirus reported
further 49 people sadly have died takes
the total number of people who've died
within 28 days of a positive test to 135
hundred and fifty two
riot police have been in a tense
standoff with protesters in melbourne
who are angry about a government mandate
for construction workers to have the
kovid 19 vaccine
sky news australia reporter julia
bradley joining us now from melbourne
hello to you thanks for joining us
what's going on
okay we've seen extraordinary scenes
unfold here in melbourne today there's
been about a six hour standoff between
police and protesters as you say over
this decision that was made by
victoria's government to mandate hover
vaccinations for the construction
workforce which comprises about three
hundred thousand people here in victoria
we've seen protests become quite violent
today police have been using tear gas
rubber bullets they've been using pepper
spray to try to disperse the crowd the
demonstrations began here at the cfmeu
headquarters which is the head office
for australia's biggest construction
union where scenes turned quite ugly
yesterday protests then went over to
victoria's parliament where police lined
the steps of that parliament they then
went over to flinders street station
which is one of our biggest train
stations here in melbourne but quite
extraordinarily we then saw protesters
take over the westgate freeway a major
freeway here in melbourne traffic was
banked up for about six kilometers
traffic came to a complete standstill
because of these protests they're angry
at about the fact that vaccinations are
going to be mandatory but also about the
fact that victoria's government made a
snap decision late last night to close
the industry for the next two weeks
okay for now thank you thanks a lot
obviously monitor events in melbourne
for you meantime projections suggest
that justin trudeau's liberal party will
return to power in canada after a close
fought election the opposition leader
erin o'toole has conceded defeat and
michelle trudeau has said the results
show he has a clear mandate to get his
country through the pandemic the 49 year
old gambled on an early election in a
bid to win an outright majority but it
thought he'd return a minority
government
jennifer r curie is set to give evidence
today about her influence in city hall
during boris johnson's time as mayor of
london it's expected the american
businesswoman who has alleged that she
had a four-year affair with the now
prime minister will be questioned by the
london assembly's oversight committee
about her role on foreign trade missions
led by mr johnson
prince andrew is said to have been
served with a sexual assault and lawsuit
after the relevant paperwork was
delivered to his u.s lawyer the duke has
denied the allegations against him
well our royal correspondent brianna
mills joining us now from buckingham
palace challenging few days ahead for
the prince not least because he's just
become a grandfather um with one of his
daughters and can't go down to see her
yeah so there was the happy news
yesterday that princess beatrice gave
birth to a baby girl
in london over the weekend but for
prince andrew it's raised questions
about where exactly is he and we know
that for the last couple of weeks he's
been
in scotland as we've seen that legal
touring and throwing the disagreements
between his lawyers and lawyers over in
america as to whether or not that sex
abuse compensation case has been
properly served
against him yesterday late in america
more court documents were filed which
virginia dufrese lawyers say prove that
the case has now been served properly
documents showing that the la lawyer has
received
those documents also other photographs
showing the legal papers that have been
filed to the high court here in london
obviously we know that the court in the
states has said that virginia dufrese
lawyers can ask the high court for help
to serve those papers as well and uh
prince andrew's legal team have until
friday to appeal against that however it
has to be said for the royal family
there are other things happening this
week that they would far rather that we
are focusing on and that includes a very
poignant tribute that many of them have
been involved in to prince philip a
documentary that will go out tomorrow
night an hour-long documentary where in
essence his grandchildren and children
narrate his life in their own words and
let's in on a few
family secrets i've watched it and it
has to be said that the moments that
they really light up is where they talk
about his mischievous and cheeky side
here's what prince william had to say
about his grandpa
let me go for family barbecues um
instead of like a mustard pot we had a
mustard tube a squeezy mustard tube
um and you used to take the lid off and
put it in your hands it gets you to hold
it it gets you to hold it
and then you squish your hands together
to fire the mustang with the ceiling it
goes smaller
he used to get in a lot of trouble for
my grandmother for covering most of the
places we had lunch and things with
mustard on the ceiling
watching a preview of the documentary it
really reminded me of the days after
prince philip died where the family was
surprisingly warm about him very
publicly in a way that we don't normally
expect from members of the royal family
but you can't help but think what prince
philip would think about it all as
camilla describing him as the epitome of
the stiff upper lip okay for now thank
you
we've been following this story for you
throughout the last few days it's a
volcano in la palma in the canary
islands it's continued to erupt spewing
lava down the mountainside this is what
it's looking like today local
firefighters captured this scene as the
wall of lava moved through villages and
towns you'd definitely turn around
wouldn't you saw that coming the lava
flow covered a large area around 5 000
people on la palma have been evacuated
to escape the erupting combre vieja
volcano
say with conviction people believe
that's how you pronounce it officials
said about a hundred properties had so
far been destroyed and no deaths or
injuries have been reported
airlines and travel firms are reporting
a surge in interest after the u.s
announced that it will relax
restrictions for passengers entering
from the uk and the eu from november
our correspondent melania vasilitovic
joining us now from the u.s embassy just
across the river here in southwest
london hello to you melania thank you um
for updating us this morning it came as
a bit of a surprise yesterday though
didn't it
yeah when boris johnson spoke to
reporters on his way to america he said
he wasn't really holding his breath that
this would happen and lo and behold this
announcement came so
you know you can take your own
conclusions as to how closely the two
governments worked on this but
nonetheless it's excellent news for
anyone who has been separated from their
loved ones with this travel ban which
lasted by about 18 months all foreign
visitors will have to show proof of
vaccination before they board the plane
they'll also need a negative cover 19
test taken within three days of that
departure airlines will be collecting
contact tracing information but once
you're in the us there's no need to
quarantine
now uh the americas centers for disease
prevention and control will decide
whether jobs that haven't been approved
in the us like the oxford astrozanika
job which many brits have will count
under this system but downing street
said that they were confident that they
would be accepted and as you mentioned
their travel firms reporting spikes in
inches british airways 700 surge in
searches for holidays to the u.s virgin
atlantic said they've actually seen a
rise in 91 in actual bookings within the
hour of the announcement and even
easyjet that doesn't even fly to the us
has seen their shares spike clearly a
sign that the travel industry has taken
that the recovery is now well and truly
underway
okay thank you
i want to tell you uh in a little bit
more detail now about why the united
states has done what it's done joining
us now from san francisco is peter chin
hong professor in infectious diseases at
the university of california um hello to
you professor thank you for joining us
on the programme this morning why do you
think now has been the time that this
has happened professor
well i think it's uh there are multiple
factors driving this particular
announcement uh first and foremost it is
a big business i mean
travel to the us from other countries
has led you know probably accounts for
about 500 billion dollars
and one of my colleagues quipped you
know new york is open but it's not
really open until the tourists are here
so that's part of it so it's much
business as humanitarian and of course
there are a lot of educational
institutions that suffered because they
haven't been scientists
students phd post docs traveling back
and forth who are non-american citizens
so i think all of this would hopefully
lead to more bi-directional exchange of
information but also business
so many people have died of uh
covenanting of course in both countries
particularly in the united states
particularly under the previous regime
one wonders why it's safe now
well i think that um
you know that that is the question of
what's changed now i think
what became apparent is that many of the
developed countries uh
exceeded the u.s in terms of overall
population vaccinated so it seems sort
of strange when
you're allowing um uh folks to come from
probably uh more vaccinated peace when
you're not allowing them and so i think
that was leading to a lot of tension and
now that tension is a little bit lifting
of course the timing is interesting as
well now that there's a little bit more
tension with the united states
around some of the political issues so
i think um
biden's hoping for more
support towards donation of the global
effort towards
vaccinating the world so i think this is
part of making nice so to speak
yeah and what about astrazeneca as a
vaccination though that was one of the
areas of concern as well wasn't it it
wasn't necessarily being recognized um
as a vaccine in the united states as
opposed to moderna and even pfizer
i think the cdc is going to look at the
list uh but it is expected that
astrazeneca would be included but that
doesn't mean that all who vaccines will
be either i'm worried about cynofarms
cyanovac you know some of the generic
manufacturers kovacson kovi shield from
india i mean these are decent vaccines
and
you know you may get the situation where
you have an over vaccinated group of
tourists coming to the u.s and you know
there's a theoretical risk of immune
exhaustion if you give to people too
many vaccines
what is the situation with covet in the
united states at the moment a lot of
people double jabbed are you already
looking at booster jabs
yeah so we're expecting the cdc decision
to rule on um boosters
either this wednesday or thursday it
will apply first to those who are 65 and
older and in two additional populations
those whose work put them at increased
risk for covet exposure like healthcare
workers as well as those with multiple
medical comorbidities so not uh everyone
in the population i think the fda was
going to was being very
um science-driven although they did
include some of the other populations
like healthcare workers who are not
included in the science um and i think
people are
sort of you know not
rushing down to get boosters so to speak
uh it's probably going to lead to a
modest uh increase in vaccinations but
again you have 80 million americans who
are not vaccinated so it's kind of like
a seesaw where you know there's a lot of
people on one end but uh
not having a lot of uh you know
bi-directional movements so to speak
and a quick thought professor on a
vaccinating children um topic of um
contention here in the united kingdom 12
to 15 year olds being vaccinated from
this week what's the situation in the
u.s well the debate right now for the 12
to 15 year olds in the us is whether or
not they'll be mandated to get vaccines
in school districts the la school
district the unified school district of
la the second largest school district in
the country recently uh announced a
mandate for that particular age group
and certain areas in the san francisco
area also uh
noted some similar mandates so i think
it's not fully fda approved yet but i
think many people depending on where you
live in the country are supportive of it
of course today's announcement of the
data for uh 11 to 5 year olds
does you know again lead to the idea
that schools eventually are going to
have this as part of a mandate
good to talk to you professor thank you
for staying up late for us we appreciate
it thank you very much indeed joining us
live from san francisco
thanks so much did you know that air
pollution isn't just bad for the
environment it's bad for our health too
[Music]
it'll be a chilly start today with some
early mist and fog patches most places
will have a dry day with brighter sunny
spells and it will feel warm in the
light winds
thicker clouds brisk winds and outbreaks
of rain will spread to northwestern
areas later
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high
air pollution levels are expected to
remain low today although there may be
the odd elevated pocket near busy roads
and urban centres
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
talking about youngsters and teenagers
just a second ago not a lost generation
but a roll up their sleeves heroic
generation that's how the children's
commissioner for england dame rachel de
souza describe britain's young people
who've lived through covet it comes
after she launched a survey asking half
a million children about how the
pandemic had impacted on them dame
rachel is with us now hello to dame
rachel thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning we hear a lot
about kids
at the moment being part of a lost
generation tell us about your survey
so this survey is the biggest survey of
its kind ever done in the world in terms
of its response rate so more than half a
million children in england from 4 to 18
have responded to us and told us about
both what they want coming out of
lockdown to thrive and what they want
for their futures and you're absolutely
right it's not a lost generation so more
than 80 percent of them have told us
that they're happy or okay but mainly
happy and they've there's an amazing
cohesion about what they want for their
futures across all gender identity
groups in all locations you know they
want to get back to school they want
great places to play to go out things to
do they've got real ambitions and hopes
for their futures and they want to
create a greener fairer world it's
fantastic they're not a lost generation
they're not a snowflake generation they
told me that explicitly i think they are
a heroic generation and i say that
because of what they've endured during
the pandemic and they've come out of
that period of isolation not having
school not seeing family all the things
that have worried them and upset them
and they've come out of that stronger
and really positive and really ready to
sort of try and you know move forward
with the country and i think we need to
listen to them and make sure we meet
their needs and put them at the center
of policy making it's it's time for them
now
and how does it depend or how much does
it depend on their living conditions or
their family situation
yes so they're they're i mean what's
really interesting is even the most
children from poorer backgrounds more
disadvantaged backgrounds children in
care have come up with the same top
things that they want they want good
physical and mental health they want a
good education they want support for
their education they want places to go
things to do and a massive 70 plus
percent of them are saying the biggest
issue for them is getting the support
they need so they can get the jobs they
need for their future they're very
focused on their careers and trust me
there's no lack of ambition in english
children i'm met the next elon musk when
i was out talking to children i went
from grimsby to hansworth to bristol to
gateshead everywhere and that they're
really ambitious lots of them saying
give us more vocational pathways we want
trades as well and we want really good
jobs so you know there's amazing
cohesion and yes more vulnerable
children ha you know are more concerned
with family life wanting thinking more
about having a greater family when
they're when they're older um
particularly children in care but in the
in the main the responses are really
similar which is great and we've got a
generation that we know what to do how
to listen to and how to look after
how glad are you to see the back of
gavin
williamson oh i thought gavin was great
and i'm really pleased to see um nahim
uh nadine sahawi take up post he
received our um
he received our report yesterday and you
know i'm really confident that he's
going to be delivering for children this
is a time when we all have to work
together public services ministers
governments opposition parties to do the
best for children i'm the children's
commissioner i'm here to be the voice of
children and work with anyone and
everyone
to really you know to really get the
best deal for children
are you sure that you thought he was
great at his job well one wonders why he
got sacked
i worked with him i thought was good man
how do you feel about um 12 to 15 year
olds having vaccinations
yeah so that's that's really really
important two things one i'm not a
scientist but i think we we definitely
always need to follow the science
whether we're talking about school
closures whether we're talking about
vaccinations
lots of 12 to 15 year olds and i've been
out around the country have told me they
want to be vaccinated i think this is a
decision that parents and children need
to take together the big thing i want to
see is really good material that
children can understand to help them
make this decision well and that's what
my office is going to be pushing for
okay good to talk to you dame um thank
you very much indeed for joining us on
the program hopefully you'll be able to
join us in the studio next time we see
you thank you
look forward to it thanks very much
thank you me too
um co2
would know more about it today than we
normally do don't we and that is because
apparently we need it for our food
supplies and if we don't get it then
we're not going to have pork and the
like and fresh lettuce and stuff on our
shelves by the end of the week and that
is because a factory is not producing
its co2 because they can't get the gas
at the right price all very complicated
isn't it what are we going to do about
it this is what quasi quartering the
business secretary told me
we're definitely looking at trying to
secure
carbon dioxide
uh uh supply
uh and it's
well i think i think we're getting that
i mean i spoke to the chancellor
yesterday
uh spoken to the the ceo of the business
an american man it's pretty imminent but
uh i'm confident today tomorrow in the
next
three this week i hope uh we have a very
clear plan
so uh crisis what crisis the we heard
from quasi quoting saying he's basically
going to fix it by the end of the week
we will see we'll have more on that
coming up in the next hour here on the
programme also we'll be taking you to
the chelsea flower show as well um after
the uh break after a break i should say
for the pandemic that the show is back
not normally in september but it is this
year opens to the public in south west
london um today obviously great big uh
pumpkins in the line um stars have
turned out in force including plenty of
royalty princess anne and the earl and
countess of wessex were all spotted at
yesterday's preview event her majesty
not there the reason for that is because
it's a little bit too late in the year
for her rupaul's drag race star crystal
was there as well djing
follow that if you can i'll try at 8.
[Music]